[Musique]
je m'appelle et me diriger et je suis
écrivaine
impressionnant 1 des siècles de
littérature nous contemplent
pourtant écrire nous savons tous le
faire ici rappelez-vous toutes ces
heures pencher sur vos cahiers peut-être
en tirant la langue pour apprendre ce
savoir faire
écrire
est aujourd'hui devenu adulte ou presque
qui écrivons nous des listes de courses
des mémos pour le bureau des courriers
administratifs
post-it rendez-vous dentiste de l'utile
du fonctionnel
aimeriez vous en faire autre chose
devenir écrivent en
écrivant
c'est ainsi que s'appelle les membres de
mes ateliers d'écriture pas des
écrivains pas encore pour certains mais
des amoureux des mots qui apprivoise une
autre forme d'écriture ni littérature ni
utile une écriture récréation
c'est pas le bon mot une écriture
recréation
le journal intime le plus célèbre le
journal d'anne frank
les mots intérieur une part dont un
rempart contre la terreur nazie
saviez vous que la glaciale reine
victoria avait tenu un journal intime
depuis ses 13 ans jusqu'à la veille de
sa mort cent quarante et un volume plus
de 8 millions de mots pour décrire dans
le détail chaque émotion quotidienne de
cette reine dont le règne de 64 ans est
resté dans l'histoire comme un symbole
d'austérité
etonnant non
le journal intime l album photo de notre
coeur il saisit au vol nos chagrins nos
tendresse nos réflexions tous petit
événement trop minuscule pour marquer
notre mémoire et qui pourtant nous
construisent jour après jour et font de
nous ce que nous sommes
écrire régulièrement c'est garder la
trace de ce chemin que l'on fait trop
souvent au courant
prendre un temps de calme pour faire le
point sur soi
nous ne sommes ni la petite anne caché
dans son grenier ni la reine du plus
grand royaume de son époque alors tenir
un journal n'est ce pas un peu frivole
voir nombriliste pourquoi le faire
pour libérer de la place dans nos têtes
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela que l'on
dresse sans relâche des listes ce qui
est posé sur le papier nous n'avons plus
à le porter nous sommes débarrassés
avec mes enfants quand il était petit et
qu'il faisait un cauchemar nous avions
un jeu écrire sur une feuille ce qu'il
avait effrayé et ensuite prendre cette
feuille est là chiffonné la déchirer la
mordre on aurait même pu la brûler
emprisonné dans le papier un monstre
peut-être vaincu
l'acte d'écrire
est rarement innocent
le geste d'écrire
donner à sa pensée l'intermédiaire de la
main
nous met en contact avec une part de
nous inaccessibles en temps normal il se
crée un décalage comme un court circuit
de la raison pour penser autrement
écrire devient alors un outil pour
communiquer avec soi même
j'en fais régulièrement l'expérience son
atelier d'écriture je lance les écrivant
sur un thème une histoire il commence à
écrire et tout d'un coup
l'un d'entre eux fond en larmes
pas toujours fort assure on s'amuse
aussi beaucoup en atelier d'écriture
mais quand cela arrive c'est que les
mots ont débloqué quelque chose
révélé une blessure tapis dans l'ombre
que l'on croyait guéri depuis longtemps
ces jours-là décrivant ressort de
l'atelier
apaisé comme soulagé d'un poids qui
n'avait même plus conscience de porter
moi même ecrivaine expérimentés je me
laisse attraper par les mots comme une
débutante je m'immerge dans l'écriture
d'un roman je laisse les personnages
hantés mes jours mes pensées mon corps
mes nuits pour mieux les écouter
et je réalise en posant le point final
que j'ai écrit sur une partie de ma vie
écrire
c'est rendre un peu de corps et de
cohérence au brouhaha incessant du monde
s'est rangé sa tête et faire le tri de
ses expériences comme orange sa maison
et fait le tri de ses placards
savez vous ce que c'est
une baguette magique
elle permet de recréer le monde tel que
l'on voudrait qu'ils soient
nos journées sont plein de frustration
d'obligations de contraintes
or celui qui tient le stylo
l'écrivain l'écrivant vous moi quand
nous tenons cette baguette magique nous
devenons des super héros
on nous en parant du sésame magique
il était une voix
ou celui ci encore on dirait que je
serais ce que je veux
quand j'écris je retrouve mon âme
d'enfant je redeviens maître du jeu
si vous saviez le nombre de casses pieds
que j'ai dit oui dans mes histoires
bon débarras
dans une histoire j'arrive même à
imaginer que mon ado range ta chambre
c'est vous dire
cette toute puissance
cette bulle où tout est possible
et jouissive
douglas kennedy nous le dit ainsi
vous ne pouvez pas contrôler la vie
vous ne pouvez pas contrôler les autres
mais vous pouvez l'écrire
alors écrire quoi comment quel est le
point de départ
à l'origine d'une histoire il ya une
question
pourquoi
pourquoi cette personne se comporte
ainsi alors cela n'a aucun sens pour moi
pourquoi cette situation at elle évolué
comme ça alors que je voulais tout le
contraire
écrire une histoire c'est simplement
tester des hypothèses pour répondre à
cette question ce pourquoi
qu'importe si l'histoire est imparfaite
incomplète surréaliste voire même
surnaturel une fois qu'elle est écrite
notre cerveau il croit
avez vous déjà été émue à la lecture
d'un roman
rayé à la description d'une scène
cocasse
des personnages vous ont-ils déjà touché
et ému agacé attendri
avez vous déjà ressenti cette tristesse
en arrivant à la fin d'un livre que vous
aimiez cette envie de repartir au début
et de recommencer le voyage
alors voyez bien que c'est réel pour
notre esprit
écrire c'est recréer la réalité
en 2018
je travaille pour une boutique de copie
et d'impression
est régulièrement entre une mamie qui
exigent chaque fois une avalanche de
photocopies couleur les photos de ses
chats
les photos sont moches vraiment vraiment
moche et la mamie infernale
à face je vous avoue elle me fascine
comment peut-elle être aussi odieuse
avec tout le monde
alors qu'elle contient autant d'amour en
elle pour ses chats
j'ai écrit mon histoire
son chat préféré est tout ce qui lui
reste de son fils unique décédé
je ne saurai jamais si mon histoire est
vraie ou pas et je ne veux pas le savoir
l'important est que cette histoire m'a
permis de comprendre pourquoi ces photos
si moche était si importante pour elle
et de faire mon travail autrement
avec le temps elle me rendait même son
sourire mon sourire en rentrant dans la
boutique
l'écriture est en pâtit
que faire de tous ces mots déposés sur
le papier
les partager
pourquoi ce partage est il si important
pour moi
est ce que partager comme ce soir ici
et ce qui donne du sens à ce que nous
faisons à ce que nous sommes
c'est aussi la condition sinequanone de
la création nous créons à partir de la
création de ceux qui nous ont précédés
même un génie comme léonard de vinci
n'aurait pas pu créer en partant de rien
les autres nous nourrissent
partager nos écrits s'y rendre un peu de
ce que nous avons reçues
il écriture est magique
elle crée une complicité instantanée et
des liens avec une force impressionnante
qui me surprend encore après des années
d'expérience
j'ai vu des coups de coeur à nico avoir
lieu en atelier d'écriture des inconnus
qui deviennent amis à la simple lecture
de quelques lignes
j'ai vécu mes propres coups de coeur
j'ai une immense gratitude pour
l'écriture
elle a fait entrer dans ma vie l'homme
que j'aime et des personnes absolument
fantastique
j'ai chaque fois rencontrer la personne
que j'attendais après l'avoir lu
c'est un merveilleux cadeau
pourquoi cette intimité si soudaine
je partage avec vous le fruit de ma
réflexion
après des années d'expérience en tant
qu'écrivaine et que lectrice
le choix de nos maux la façon de les
arranger entre le rythme de nos phrases
quand nous écrivons
c'est la partie la plus authentique de
nous qui transparaît même dans ce que
l'on veut cacher
celui qui nous lie ne connaîtra pas nos
secrets bien sûr
mais il comprendra à un niveau
subliminal notre identité profonde
nos corps communique avec des phéromones
dont nous n'avons pas conscience
j'ai la conviction que nos esprits et
nos coeurs
partage
communique échange avec cette part de
nous qui cimente nos maux
j'emprunte chez mots de philippe besson
pour vous le dire autrement
je t'écris
est-ce que tu écrire
c'est être avec toi
le plus difficile finalement dans cette
histoire d'écriture c'est de se sentir
légitime pour écrire se donner le droit
de prendre le stylo ignorer cette petite
voix qui susurre que on ne sait pas
écrire ça n'intéressera personne ici
j'allais plutôt passer l'aspirateur pour
faire quelque chose d'utile
vous connaissez le nom de l'inventeur de
l'aspirateur
à moi non plus
mais nous connaissons charles baudelaire
et les fleurs du mal ernest hemingway le
vieil homme et la mer margaret atwood la
servante écarlate albert camus la peste
ou l'étranger george sand la petite
fadette et tant d'autres
même si nous ne les avons pas lu leurs
oeuvres nous appartiennent nous
connaissons leurs histoires leurs
personnages font partie de notre
identité culturelle
me croyez pas
un séducteur est un
don gyan molière
combien d'entre nous ont eu l'héroïsme
n'ayons pas peur des mots de lire proust
marne ont pourtant nous connaissons
l'histoire de sa madeleine
et celle d'esmeralda ils sont bossu né
sous la plume de victor hugo dans notre
dame de paris
le légendaire nez de cyrano de bergerac
créé par edmond rostand
une autre chouchou à tous dans le monde
entier le petit prince d'antoine de
saint-exupéry
avec sa rose et son renard que l'on
voudrait temps d'apprivoiser
impressionnants ces noms qui traverse
les siècles
alors et je le droit d'écrire si je ne
m'appelle pas emile zola
qu'en pensez vous
voulons-nous naître qu'utile
construire nos vies sur cette valeur si
pragmatiques l'utilité vraiment
nous sommes beaucoup plus que ça
écrire
est une façon d'exister disait flaubert
nous en avons tous le droit
ce soir
prenons ce précieux sésame
il était une fois
et vous
quel sera votre histoire
[Applaudissements]